這裡是AI101,
全網最幽默的AI新聞,
OpenAI最新報告,
點名北京的月資案面,
指控這家人工智慧公司用對抗式模型蒸餾,
大規模抽取OpenAI的模型能力。
怎麼抽?沒有人破解密碼,
操作者先拿到一段加密推理,
翻到新對話,
要求同一體系的模型,
逐字解碼。
等於沒有撬保險箱,
讓模型自己念出內容,
而且量很大,
短短兩天,
就湧進大約16000次請求。
這些是抽取嘗試
不代表都成功
OpenAI也只把核心群集
連到閱知暗面相關人士
為什麼推理這麼值錢
最後答案
通常不含解題過程
推理過程才看得出
模型怎麼拆解問題
修正錯誤
值錢的不只是答案
是得到答案的方法
拿到推理之後呢
讓強大的教師模型當示範
訓練規模小
成本低的學生模型去模仿
這就叫知識蒸餾
不過蒸餾本身不是駭客手法
早在2014年
研究人員就把它整理成正式方法
真正越線的是怎麼拿資料
開一堆假賬號
透過代理服務
把別人的模型變成免費教師
說到偷學
同一個7月
白宮也開過火
7月22日
白宮指控越制暗面
為了開發Kimi K3
徵留了Anthropic的Fable
財政部長也說
正在考慮制裁
把7月攤開來看更巧
7月17日
越制暗面發佈Kimi K3
7月22日
白宮指控才隔兩天
7月24到25日
OpenAI就偵測到大批異常請求
7月28日前全面阻斷
可是時間軸也有破綻
Fable
5到7月1日才恢復全球開放
離K3發佈只隔約16天
研究者質疑這夠不夠取樣
訓練測試再發布
K3全靠Fable的說法
因此被削弱
回頭看
月之暗面早就被點名過
今年2月
Anthropic就指控月之暗面
用假賬號跟Cloud交換超過340萬次
不過最大宗其實是minimax
次數更多
被白宮威脅制裁之後
月支暗面也沒有退讓
7月27日照原定計劃
公開Kimi K3的完整權重
精確說是開放權重
檔案一旦被下載
就收不回來了
至於讓模型自己唸的那招
8月10日
另一組研究人員發論文證明
重播加密推理
確實可能讓較弱模型解除內容
研究涵蓋OpenAI
Anthropic和Google
漏洞之外
事情還升到國安層級
9月8日
NIC,FBI和CIS
聯合點名月支案面等中國公司
工業規模針流美國前沿模型
隔天
中國商務部反駁沒有根據
揚言將採取反制
吵到這個地步
OpenAI反而很晚才開口
直到9月30日
才首次公開7月事件細節
離全面阻斷約64天
OpenAI說
已封住這條跨對話重播路徑
但其他部署仍要補強
細節公開了
事情卻還沒有落垂
OpenAI沒有公開IP
付款資料等歸因證據
月值暗面也還沒有主點回應
到10月1日
美國製裁名單也沒有新增月值暗面
這場爭議還沒有定案
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息